he is simply telling the story of
americans he said it's more important
now than ever to have a feel-good piece
in a newscast to illustrate the whole of
the country it's the back roads it's the
smaller towns and i think it's important
to get out there and represent those
folks too and that's what takes steve
hartman on the road what is it that you
think your stories do for people
the ones who are at home who are
watching
what do those stories give to them
what i'm trying to do through my work is
is remind people of what america is
really all about by and large people are
good and i just want to remind people of
that you know week in and week out
is that your goal for each story it is
it is
to reaffirm again restore faith in
humanity
and and present a true picture it's not
like i'm presenting just a rosy image of
america i feel like i'm presenting the
real picture of what america is all
about for you
what is it that makes a good story what
is it that makes it the one we generally
try to pick something that when all is
said and done and the story's over that
people will feel something and ideally
we want people to feel overwhelming joy
but how does he find these gems we don't
get a lot of people sending us ideas
but that's okay we'll go out and find
them something that seems so little but
it somehow just really makes a big
difference and sometimes one person's
life and sometimes many people's lives
so what's made a difference in his after
years of storytelling the story of nora
and dan
and that was a story about a little girl
who was in a grocery store and she saw
this grumpy old man and she asked him
for a hug
and what she didn't know what she would
have no way of knowing is that the man
had just lost his wife about six months
earlier and he'd given up his reason for
living i like that story because it kind
of symbolizes all the stories
that we look for in that it was about as
insignificant little thing or seemingly
insignificant little thing that made a
huge impact and i think we can all agree
it's hartmann's stories that make an
impact on each one of us heather mills
live local now